hi there steve kaufman here um i'm not
really sure what i'm going to talk about
here today but it's going to be about
education and it comes from my um
experience on this uh
this exchange email exchange with with
language and literacy teachers
uh
and
and i mentioned in the previous uh video
how they
went uh
a majority of them see literacy as some
kind of uh you know inevitably in
intertwined with ideology
uh one person said you know obviously uh
you know uh teaching literacy teaching
language uh
is in inevitably involved with democracy
and republicanism
was one statement from one of these
teachers
so i pointed out that actually uh
far more advances were made in in
literacy
education in
quite undemocratic states like
china
the soviet union and cuba
than
took place for example in a democratic
country like like india
and you know she quotes me jefferson and
all kinds of american stuff i'm not
american uh
the world
to me the model is not america
um
literacy is literacy there could be uh
you know as i mentioned messages that
are
implicitly political or ideolo
ideological but you can also read a
manual on how to
how to i don't know
assemble
furniture that you bought somewhere so
literacy is just about reading period
what struck me is here you have all
these people
talking to each other via email it takes
a fair amount of time to do this
basically
very little of what they say is is of
any use most of it they've heard many
times before
uh occasionally there's some reference
to something that they're doing in class
that might be of of interest to someone
else a lot of it is just repeating a lot
a lot of the sort of pseudo-academic
gibberish that they learned
at school
all about discourse and post-modern and
i don't know all these terms
um
and of course they but they don't just
do it by email they go to conferences
uh they sit down together for two days
and stay in hotels and
they have meetings and i'm just
wondering and i know here in our
education system in british columbia
there are regular
professional days where teachers go off
and supposedly
uh
you know improve their skills how much
of these conferences are spent
simply parroting back and forth things
that they have heard many many times
before
um
one of them mentioned one of the
commenters mentioned
or asked me what i thought of the
comprehensible output theory and i
didn't know what that was but i looked
it up
on the internet it's so handy to do that
these days i saw a crash and of course
he
he pooh-poohed it he said it didn't
amount to very much it wasn't a very
significant part of language learning
um and then i looked at what this
particular person whose name was meryl
swain had to say
and she said that output helps us
identify gaps in our knowledge
uh
she had a few things to say that that
that made sense to me and i agree i
think that some degree of output is very
useful in language training first of all
you are training yourself in
in retrieving what you have learned
so that the practice of speaking is in
itself something you gotta practice
it's just that uh it's not always
possible to do so
but where you have the opportunity you
you obviously should on the other hand
if you don't feel
you know confident enough there's no
there's no urgency to speak i think you
can continue to learn and acquire
vocabularies without speaking vocabulary
the second thing is you know i did some
reading a while ago on this whole issue
of mirror neurons
and it was pointed out that if you are a
piano player and you hear a piano being
played that your neurons will fire the
same way as if you are actually playing
but it only works if you are yourself a
piano player so i'm just guessing but i
i have the feeling that if you do some
speaking it primes your neurons to some
extent and makes you a little more
receptive to what you're listening to
so i mean
as i pointed out in a little article
that i wrote you know yes input is key
yes the brain will pick it up but the
brain misses things
and that's why
anything we can do to increase the
attentiveness and the general alertness
of the brain
is good so general alertness is one
thing
uh and maybe this whole priming of the
pump you know the fact that you have
tried to speak makes you more alert and
then second of all to make you more
attentive to specific um things that
you're trying to learn like it could be
the use of certain cases in russian and
so forth and so on and that's where some
of the things again that we do at link
like the flash carding uh being
corrected when you speak when you write
i mean these things don't bring about
it's not like you immediately learn if
you
go through 50 flash cards you don't
immediately learn 50 words and to try
and do that is silly because some words
you'll learn right away and they'll
stick and some other words you can look
at them 10 times you won't remember them
so so that it's just a matter of just
continuing to do it and it's just
making you just that little bit
attentive until eventually those words
become sticky
so being corrected is a bit like that
you won't necessarily get it right the
next time or the next time but being
corrected and corrected and correct you
are you eventually might start to notice
that in the language a little bit more
um
words the same way
so
but then i went to see i found her on
the web meryl swain and i went through
her piece and of course it's so full of
this
academic language and they're gonna do
research on
you know they found five people in a
class and who struggled to say this in
french and they said something else and
it reflected the influence of their
english language or their attempt to to
apply a rule
that they had felt they knew for french
but in fact it didn't apply and so the
thing didn't come out write or something
again extrapolating all kinds of
theories i just think it's it's just
overly complicated
listening is good reading is good
speaking is also good
if you have the opportunity to do so but
you needn't do a lot of it uh if you are
not in a position where you can speak
without paying for a teacher which costs
money or without accosting people on the
street
uh to practice your conversation well be
happy with what you can do listening and
reading so i i think there's a
tremendous tendency to overcomplicate
these things and i just wonder in our
education budget i mean if i look at our
universities if i look at what people
study there
and the number of professors especially
in the humanities
who are so proud of of doing research on
obscure subjects but this is all in our
education budget if we spend
whatever it is six seven percent of our
gdp on education how much of it goes
into useful learning activities and how
much of it goes into supporting
this
educational superstructure
infrastructure whatever you want to call
it which is largely incestuous just kind
of feeding on itself let's all gather
together and drink coffee and eat donuts
and talk about stuff that we've all
heard before
uh it kind of is my feeling
so
i just wonder about that i i think given
the fact that education is so important
to everyone it gives them a yeah maybe
this is an ideological argument here
that that i i'm sort of prejudiced that
i say people should
should uh you know read better and speak
more languages but the fact matter is
that people by and large want to and
they benefit from that so
maybe that's a prejudice maybe there's
another mode which is let's say the
hunter-gatherer mode
uh you know we'd all have a life
expectancy of uh 25 or 30 years but we
wouldn't have to read
we wouldn't have capitalism we wouldn't
have any
pharmaceutical companies we'd just you
know we just die after 25 30 years the
way we used to so
but i don't know that that's a real
option so given the society that we do
have language literacy is very important
and are we spending our money wisely
when i see what happens in language
instruction i doubt it
what is the real
you know efficiency of our education
system how much of it is spent on these
relatively useless activities that amuse
the practitioners but have relatively
little benefit for the people who are
actually learning
i look forward to hearing your comments
thank you